hello everybody so uh I think this will
be really interesting today because this
is not a room that I'm normally in I
called this blue cering the network
State because I have this idea in my
head of if we are going to achieve this
thing which is a
decentralized uh world this network
State idea I think we need dirty
fingernails and callous hands just as
much as we need big huge brains and
that's kind of what I'm going to talk
about today I think when I was first
thinking about this talk a lot of people
here might think you don't need blue
collar to have decentralization and then
your next thought might be wondering why
someone like me who's mostly known for
laundr mats and car washes and investing
in boring businesses that are mostly run
by 65y olds uh or plus who really think
crypto is a Dan Brown book or maybe
think that uh this has to do with air
conditioning why am I here why would I
come speak an event like this well the
reason is bology and I became friends
and we realize we have this oddly shared
Mission and the mission is essentially I
come from an industry finance that I
spent 15 years doing Investment Banking
and asset management and private equity
and I realize probably like many of you
that Finance is one of the most
unnecessarily
overregulation for the most part and yet
we're so over regulated and I don't know
about you all but when I was younger and
coming out of college they told us Wall
Street was where you want to be that was
where all the money was and that was
where the big mines went actually way
before where we're at today in Silicon
Valley was really the play and then I
went to the data over the last couple
years as we've built this big business
and if you can see what it turns out is
traditional pass AKA Wall Street
Consulting compared to acquisition
through entrepreneurship or laundromat
ownership amongst other things actually
has an asymmetric upside to ownership
employment does not very hard to make
incredible amounts of wealth as an
employee and so once I started thinking
about this I realized you know do we
have to have Wall Street to do
Acquisitions I've spent the last three
years taking what I think is a
relatively complex subject Acquisitions
and not using the word Acquisitions
using the word buying boring businesses
online because I had this belief that
actually everyday normal humans could
buy businesses and what's happened since
then is kind of interesting we get about
a 100 million views a month talking
about how to acquire our neighborhood
community stores we have 5 million
followers across social we've had 5,000
students learn boring business
Acquisitions and we've had 500 people we
actively tag as having bought businesses
that have done more than $150 million in
profit these are normal humans teachers
Engineers a bunch of people that got
laid off at tech companies and then
decided that they wanted to own instead
of be employed and I think this is
really really important because you know
if many of you are fans of of TB like I
am what does he always talk about he
talks about skin in the game and
incentive alignment and that that is how
to decide if a decision is good or bad
and what I realized is it's really bad
if we don't actually own our communities
and it's really bad if you don't own the
things that you frequent that you're
employed at and that you spend at but
here's a problem with that we don't own
our communities or the businesses
they're in the big they own and we buy
three companies own the entire soft
drink
Market KKR Blackstone
Carlile uh big institutions bought one
in every four homes in the US in 2022
one out of every four single family
homes in 2022
groceries owned by about 10 companies in
the US so they own what we drink they
own where we live they own what we eat
and they even own the companies that
build the houses that we live in and so
increasingly we have had this Insidious
creep of Wall Street into owning
everything and could you imagine living
in a neighborhood or a block where there
was a McDonald's house and there was a
Walmart house and you were living in
between in the Target house we actually
wouldn't stand for it in our homes but
we've stood for it in our businesses and
how many of you have been at a Starbucks
and felt the difference between a
Starbucks and your local coffee shop the
difference is visceral and that's
because one you might know the owner
they might even remember your order and
the other they don't care and
the CEO has never stepped in the store
now I am a capist to the max I do
believe that but I think that there is a
difference between making things not
simplified so that the many can own as
opposed to helping other people get rich
alongside us I had a a private Equity
CEO that I worked for for a number of
years who I thought very highly of and
he told me something that I've never
forgotten it's probably why I'm public
on the internet now which is he said do
you know what we do in private Equity
Cody I was like well we buy businesses
we lever them we sell them and he's like
we get rich quietly we get rich quietly
and that just never sat that well with
me because I think we've seen the second
and third order effects of a very small
amount of people having all the wealth
and it's not good for
anybody and yet that's what's happening
one out of every three transactions in
the US
in m&a was done by private Equity firms
the big guys keep getting bigger and the
little guys hurt and because of that our
world looks like logos and not faces and
it's actually worse than this if you
were to follow the puppet strings up you
would see that these companies by and
large are held by a few holding
companies and a few private Equity Funds
this is what I stand against and what I
think we've started to normalize now
what happens when you normalize things
when you simplify things do people love
that no they want it to be complex
because then we s sounds sophisticated
and intelligent but complex doesn't help
people understand so today I have no big
theorems or mathematical predictions you
guys all have very strong Brilliant
Minds in here having a vision of the
future all I have instead is maybe a
thought and the thought is this that
what if the people that are most open to
your ideas today that actually are most
aligned with
them are being left behind a little bit
and so I thought I'd play a game and the
game was basically this most small
business owners across the world Europe
the US even Japan are uh baby boomer
generation what's interesting about this
generation is they own most of the
businesses but they're having less
children uh at least in developed
Nations than they are before and their
children's they want to be on YouTube or
Tik Tok they don't want to run a
laundromat and so increasingly these
businesses have nowhere to transition to
if anybody's been following what's
happening in Japan Japan believes that
they might have the worst worst economic
crisis that they've had in decades
because of one thing business is closing
and the Next Generation not wanting to
own them imagine that for a second
there's actually so many businesses that
will close that it will impact their
local
communities so I said let's play a game
this is my small business owners owning
parents say hi to S and laor everybody
and they are your prototyp prototypical
65-year-old who uh plays on Main Street
and I had them do something that's
probably not going to surprise you guys
that much but I had them go through B's
account and every Twitter account that
had buzzwords related to network State
and I said just do me one thing just
write down all the words you don't
understand and they said
there's a
lot and then and then I kind of you know
got off my high horse and was like I I
don't know half of these you know there
is a whole different language that you
guys have there is slang there is
terminology there is physics language in
there there is you know making fun of a
different type of human inside there but
guess what there's also not look at how
many vowels are in most of those words
and here's the problem with that I had
my mom look does everybody know this
guy look at this bio incredible
she looked at it I think she exploded
she's like can you explain every word to
me on this bio because I don't
understand any of them now I actually
thought it was pretty good and I had a
chuckle about this also uh and I like
the guy hopefully he's here and he's not
like well forget that woman um but
here's my
problem if people don't understand
things what do they do they tear them
down if people don't understand things
they're fearful of them by and large
that's just how we're wired as humans
and so if this whole group of humans
thinks that what you're going to do is
something they don't understand and
could harm them then that's probably not
going to be great for us long term so if
we truly want this it needs to be filled
with this these are electricians and pl
plumers who don't understand Twitter
bios and in fact I think B talked about
this he says we can't assume all these
things will continue to be going on in
the future we can't assume it but who's
going to fix it are the people that are
going to fix these things in this room I
don't know we employ hundreds of bluecar
workers at the companies that we invest
in and they own and guess what they're
not on Twitter they're not here but I
think you guys have a unique opportunity
to change that perspective we have an
aay on my investment team and it is this
do you want to look right or do you want
to win and I think often in investing we
want to look right and not win but in
fact the average American reads at a
sixth grade reading level the average
European seventh grade Geniuses over
here the problem with it is you can't
just decentralize with tech and money
that's useful but I think you need the
popular vote too and look what the
average reading level in Europe gets you
not very much understanding so in order
to build a city we need all these things
but we don't have them and Thomas Soul
does everybody know who that is one of
my favorite economists as a saying and
I'm going to butcher it slightly but
it's like the problem isn't that Johnny
can't think the problem isn't that
Johnny can't write or or read the
problem is that Johnny confuses thinking
with feeling and I think that's not the
problem of this group the problem of
this group is actually they don't speak
your language they've totally been left
behind and so my only thought that I
want to leave this group is is what if
the most intelligent Among Us can speak
the simplest not the most
complex and maybe it's not the natural
state of the universe increasing in
complexity that we want to strive for I
get a lot of hate on the internet for
simplifying things you guys get a lot of
hate for having new and novel novel
ideas but maybe that's okay because some
of the best all the way down here on the
end Hemingway MacArthur like McCarthy
these writers spoke at a fourth to sixth
grade uh reading level or wrote at that
level you want to know who's all the way
at the far end anybody guess the
government the really stupid have to
sound really smart because they're not
smart enough to simplify and I don't
think that's this room the last thing I
want to say is I think it's really
really important how we name things
remember the deplorables in 2016 US
phenomenon sounds a little bit like d
cels we got to be careful who we name
and ostracize because they may be the
future of determining who outlines or
Outlaws this movement and who doesn't I
have a theory that the winners will be
those who have really big Ideas really
simplified and they bring the hard
workers because I think Freedom comes
when we own our communities own our
income and we own the ideological future
I love this quote the problem with
communication is the illusion that it's
been
accomplished do we want to look smart or
do we want to win and that's what I
would leave you guys with today thank
you so much for having
me